ça commence par un mensonge vous avez
remarqué à peine il arrive sur scène et
on se retrouve face à un comportement
complètement humain le mensonge est en
fait le mensonge c'est quelque chose
absolument fondamental dans les
relations humaines vous ne vous en êtes
peut-être pas rendu compte mais tous les
jours du matin au soir du lundi au
vendredi incluant le samedi et le
dimanche avec la famille les amis vous
mental tout le temps tout en tout temps
et en fait c'est normal puisque le
mensonge est un fluidifiant sociale
c'est très clairement aujourd'hui ce qui
vous permet d'être là aujourd'hui d'être
en société et non pas reclus au fond
d'une caverne tout seul comme un ermite
parce que ces sales mensonges
un fluidifiant sociale on va voir qu'en
fait le mensonge on peut le détecter
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que des
scientifiques des chercheurs aujourd'hui
essaye de faire notamment avec l'aide
d'une intelligence artificielle
imaginons demain on vous donne la
possibilité de développer un projet qui
soit celui de programmer une
intelligence artificielle capable de
détecter les mensonges
quelles seraient les points clés sur
lesquels vous pourriez vous basez et
bien en fait les études en héros en
neurosciences donc on va parler de
psychologie d'anthropologie de
neurologie
les études en or is en neurosciences
depuis les quarante cinquante dernières
années ont tendance à montrer un peu
tout la même chose
il existe en fait six points clés qui
sont absolument fondamentales qui font
partie de la nature humaine
par extension certains points clés on
les retrouvera également chez d'autres
amis mammifères tels que des chiens des
chats des lémuriens ou des grands singes
des primates il faut savoir que certains
primates peuvent avoir tendance à
tromper
leurs congénères y compris par extension
aussi les corbeaux les corbeaux sont
aussi dotés d'une intelligence très
intéressante à étudier mais restons
simplement sur l'humain quels sont les
points clés sur lequel vous allez
pouvoir vous basez pour développer une
intelligence artificielle capable de
détecter les mensonges et bien le
premier point clé qui nous intéresse le
premier élément qui est vraiment à la
base de toute relation et de toute
perception de toute compréhension de la
réalité
je viens de le dire c'est la perception
si vous êtes capable de comprendre le
monde extérieur aujourd'hui c'est tout
simplement parce que vous êtes doté d'un
système de perception
un système qui fonctionne à l'aide des
organes des sens qui marche par rapport
à ce que vous allez voir par rapport ce
que vous entendez et qui vend
automatiquement mettre en relation vos
connaissances avec ce que vous voyez
avec ce que vous entendez à cela on
rajoute des filtres tels que le filtre
culturel le filtre psychologique
le poids de la religion etc etc si bien
que vous avez nous avons tous une
connaissance plus ou moins précise de
notre réalité
j'ai bien dit de notre réalité puisqu'il
ya une réalité différente pour chacun de
vous eh bien lorsque vous allez être
dans cette logique de programmer une
intelligence artificielle et bien vous
serez obligé de tenir compte de cet
élément qui est la perception la vôtre
puisque vous allez le programmer mais
également le ressenti de l'autre
personne est ce normal dans certains cas
de se trouver dans une situation dans
laquelle on peut perdre ses moyens
eh bien oui c'est tout à fait normal
imaginons vous vous retrouvez devant un
tribunal
situation un peu délicate j'espère pas
très courante pour vous j'espère je vais
petit sourire dans la seine bon c'est
votre vie après on fait ce que vous
voulez bon quoi qu'il en soit à un
moment donné vous allez devoir tenir
compte de la notion de perception
puisque cette notion est bien elle est
absolument intrinsèque
on ne peut pas l'éviter elle est
omniprésente et les là on fait avec
deuxième élément clés sur lesquels nous
allons pouvoir nous baser c'est le
système de défense au système de défense
qui est en fête et
extrêmement rapide trait aux plats puis
sur qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est vrai
tu vois bien hop je l'arrêté
vous avez vous n'avez pas forcément vu
la situation de ce cette personne qui
est juste devant moi au premier rang et
qui ne s'attendait absolument pas à
recevoir une boulette de papier vous ne
vous y attendais pas pas vraiment eh
bien j'ai pu percevoir une jolie
expression de surprise
à un moment donné qui est arrivé comme
ça subitement en une fraction de seconde
et cette expression de surprise s'est
transformé en une modification
comportementale qui consistait à essayer
d'attraper la boulette en fait sans le
vouloir
monsieur ici au premier rang a eu un
réflexe ce que qu'on appelle un art que
réflexe sans cerveau a automatiquement
analysés ce qui se passait devant lui
c'est à dire le système de perception
fonctionnant en temps réel aperçu un
objet pour le coup ici physique qui
arrivaient vers lui et le système de
perception a dit non mais là il n'y a
pas danger je peux le prendre
maintenant on va recommencer la même
chose on n'aura pas la même réaction
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné si
vous percevez qu'il n'y a pas de danger
vous aurez tendance à attraper la chose
donc d'une surprise on va déboucher sur
une autre émotion notamment ça peut être
de la colère et d'un autre côté on
perçoit qu'il ya un risque
et là ça peut déboucher sur d'autres
émotions pilotées notamment les notions
de base
ça pourrait être la peur la peur qui
nous poussera à reculer la peur qui nous
pousserait avoir des réactions
totalement automatique et ça nous amène
directement au troisième point qui va
nous intéresser qui est celui ci les
émotions primaire universelle il a été
démontré depuis les années 70 ce que
nous ressentons tous tout le temps des
émotions et qu'elles sont en fait au
nombre de sept
bien sûr il peut y en avoir d'autres qui
seraient des émotions secondaire qui
vont se mélanger en fête des émotions
primaires mais les émotions que nous
ressentons au plus profond de notre
cerveau sans ces émotions si dont
notamment la peur que je viens de citer
ses émotions que nous ressentons de
manière complètement inconsciente vont
donner naissance à des comportements ces
comportements peuvent être extrêmement
rapide
on appelle ça des micro-expressions et
une micro expressions peu ça grésy
devant moi une micro expressions peut à
un moment donné flashé sur le visage en
une fraction de seconde on parle cette
fois ci d'un délai qui va de 5 centièmes
de seconde à 50 centièmes de seconde
ce sont des réflexes et ses réflexes et
bien tenez vous bien il apparaît sur le
visage de manière complètement
instantanée et on va les retrouver
exactement les mêmes émotions active en
fait les mêmes muscles faciaux et bien
on va le retrouver dans toutes les
cultures
qu'il s'agisse d'une autre monde
occidental où un monde oriental et
également sur des îles désertes où il y
a que quelques peuples n'ayant jamais
été en contact avec avec l'homme blanc
et bien en fait on va retrouver les
mêmes émotions qui ont flashé en une
fraction de seconde c'est ce qu'on
appelle les micro-expressions est
aujourd'hui est bien la science c'est
que une micro expressions est un signal
fiable d'une émotion ressentie au moment
précis où elle apparaît sur le visage ce
n'est pas rien regardons cette vidéo non
moins homogène
[Applaudissements]
another one love
m
et voilà un arrêt sur image intéressant
barack obama qui n'a pu s'empêcher de
montrer une micro expressions plutôt une
émotion mais qui peut apparaître soit
forme du micro expressions et là on a du
mépris
or rien que ça troisième élément pardon
4éme élément sur lequel nous allons
pouvoir nous baser on va parler cette
fois ci de ce qu'on appelle la boucle du
confort la boucle du confort qui se
produit de manière extrêmement
inconsciente extrêmement rapide
on va faire un essai j'ai besoin de
trois personnes trois volontaires pour
un test
madame monsieur l'autre personne à j'ai
trois personnes ici c'est très bien
venez venez venez vent moi y'a rien
voyons nous on est seul ici
tranquillement bien comment vous
appelez-vous sylvie alice et guy parfait
et vous pouvez les applaudir quand même
ils ont fait l'effort bien pour cette
expérience je vais vous demander de
fermer les yeux
mais attention vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de tricher et d'essayer de
les ouvrir parce que je pense que on
vous regarde vous allez fermer les yeux
je vais vous pilotez source sur cette
estrade pendant quelques secondes vous
pouvez fermer les yeux et après on va
faire un exercice
ensemble vous pouvez y alliez aucun
obstacle par ici les autres vous fermez
bien les yeux j'ai vu des yeux qui
s'ouvre ce n'est pas bien
vous fermez les yeux on va y aller à
reculons rassurez vous tout va bien
voilà pardon tout va bien ok parfait
vous restez là vous ne bougez pas
surtout vous fermez les yeux et on va y
aller
ici à lisieux du cialis
vous pouvez vous laisser conduire et
voilà parfait maintenant ouvrez les yeux
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux à l'isi ça
va tout va bien comment vous sentez-vous
bien parfait on est vous êtes sûr que
vous sentez bien nous ça va ça va avec
un petit nombre d'appels qui me dit ça
va pas si bien que ça plus également une
réaction que vous pouvez peut-être voir
au niveau de la bouche un la température
monte on en arrive au cinquième élément
qui est le système nerveux sympathique
en situation de tension ou de stress
eh bien on va ressentir une accélération
du rythme cardiaque une accélération de
la respiration des tensions qui
apparaissent et tout un tas de réactions
qui sont absolument incontrôlable c'est
l'augmentation de température et voilà
c'est même s'il vous dit ça va bien son
corps montrent le contraire
vous savez quoi vous allez allez vous
recevoir
tout va bien vous n'aviez personnes
devant vous donc ça va aller vous pouvez
reprendre votre place merci beaucoup
on les applaudit
la boucle du confort vous l'expliquer
brièvement de façon très simple en
situation de tension ou de stress
nous avons tendance à faire des gestes
qui sont relativement lent relativement
large relativement souple nous avons
tendance à être détendu lorsque nous
sommes dans une situation où il y à un
malaise
oui un peu de stress eh bien nous
pouvons avoir tendance à toucher frotter
gratter manipuler un objet ce recul est
notamment avoir tout un tas d'autres
contacts tels que tirer sur sur ses
cheveux se gratter frotter manipuler un
objet etc
l'objectif étant d'envoyer des signaux
nerveux et au cerveau qui en fait va
rassurer le cerveau n'oublions pas que
votre cerveau et dans une boîte
il est enfermé dans une boîte et il a
besoin d'information est le seul moyen
pour avoir des informations
et bien c'est simplement de demander des
stimuli or sur une main nous avons entre
5 et 30 terminaisons nerveuses
donc nous avons tendance justement à
bouger beaucoup les mains nous avons
tendance à essayer de justement
d'envoyer un maximum de d'application à
notre cerveau dans une situation comme
celle qu'on a vécue il a juste un
instant eh bien on est des personnes qui
étaient je pense assez pétrifié par la
situation et je vais remercier d'être
venu d'avoir participé à ce jeu pétrifié
par la situation et on avait un
comportement qui était un comportement
d'autocontrôle là justement l'objectif
n'est pas d'avoir des gestes qui ce qui
pourrait trahir leur stress mais au
contraire essayer de s'auto contrôler un
maximum c'est à dire que dans certains
cas eh bien on va voir des gestes que
qui seront freinées qui seront plus
proches du corps
des gestes qui sont entre guillemets
anormaux par rapport au comportement de
référence de la personne le sixième
élément puisqu'on avait vu le cinquième
qui est qu'ils sont les réactions
nerveuse le sixième élément en fait
extrêmement facile à comprendre
là on veut l'appeler l'environnement
nous ne ferons pas dans l'air d'un
possible
nous vivons dans un environnement avec
des d'autres personnes nous sommes dans
un environnement avec des interactions
avec vos collègues du des collaborateurs
des clients des fournisseurs des amis de
la famille
vous êtes constamment en interaction
avec les autres et l'environnement et
bien en fait c'est simplement l'endroit
où vous vous situez
sous-entendu vous avez un territoire
votre territoire vous serez toujours
mieux sur votre territoire dans votre
fauteuil au milieu du salon ou sur votre
poste de travail que sur le poste de
travail de quelqu'un d'autre
eh bien ce sera un élément à prendre en
compte aussi puisqu'en fait un malaise
ou un stress peut être originaire d'inde
un changement d'environnement d'une
modification qui fait que la personne
pourrait se sentir un peu moins à l'aise
ce sont six éléments sur lesquels vous
pourriez vous basez pour détecter les
mensonges ou du moins déjà dans un
premier temps commençait à décoder les
comportements de vos interlocuteurs
mais mais il ya toujours un mais dans
l'histoire on est de plus en plus en
train de nous parler d'intelligence
artificielle
d'ici dix ans considérant allez on va
dire 2030
l'intelligence artificielle sera presque
partout aujourd'hui on commence à voir
apparaître dans des téléphones plus tard
on l'aura dans les téléviseurs dans des
montres peut-être même dans des
lentilles que vous pourriez porter des
lentilles qui vont améliorer non pas
seulement la vue mais peut-être vous
permettre d'enregistrer ce n'est pas une
utopie
je vous garantis que les chercheurs sont
actuellement en train de chercher à
développer ce type de produits on peut
imaginer une intelligence artificielle
développés pour aider la police pour
aider les douaniers ou des recruteurs on
peut très bien imaginer à quoi cette
intelligence artificielle spécialisé
dans la détection des mensonges à quoi
elle pourrait servir
ok vous souvenez votre téléphone votre
premier téléphone
alors oui pour les plus jeunes d'entre
vous le premier téléphone c'était
peut-être un smartphone
moi j'ai des souvenirs de mon premier
téléphone qui ressemblaient plutôt un
talkie walkie de l'armée qui pesé lourd
et qui irradiait la tête c'était voilà
assez grand et puis c'est devenu de plus
en plus petit tout petit
et puis c'est redevenu grand avec le
smartphone et ses téléphones à ne
permettait pas grand chose mis à part
téléphoner envoyer des sms
imaginons maintenant que à côte
des téléphones que vous avez on va dire
allez prenons même la situation vous
avez votre téléphone actuel sans même
imaginer ce que vous aurez comme
téléphone en 2030
imaginons votre smartphone ou votre
tablette imaginons votre webcam skype
tout simplement doté d'une intelligence
artificielle capable de détecter les
mensonges ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que vous serez capable de
voir les mensonges de vos interlocuteurs
en temps réel ouais génial attendait le
mensonge est un fluidifiant social
retirer le fluidifiant social qu'est ce
qui se passe
vous avez vraiment envie de tout dire à
tout le monde tout le temps
et qu'est ce qui se passe si votre
interlocuteur subitement vous dit dès
qu'un con je ne t'aime pas j'ai pas
envie d'être laid avec toi
aujourd'hui vous fait un grand sourire
on me dit oui mais c'est bien parfait
continue et demain il vous dira un tel
qu'un con ou alors c'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui dira ça et les
relations humaines après qu'est ce que
ça donnera nous sommes des humains nous
mentons et nous devons mentir pour
assurer notre cohésion
merci
[Applaudissements]